It was new year's Eve December the 31st 192 80 competence started the day
as Roman emperor,
but he fell to an assassination plot orchestrated by his mistress. Masia first.
She tried poisoning him, but because he was already drunk,
comidas quickly fell out and vomited the toxin before it could take effect,
then Masia resulted to less subtle methods is she simply sent a wrestler into
the embers chambers to strangle him. Comatose was dead.
And so within was the nother and denied dynasty as he had no children of his own
lands, never adopted any heirs.
The question now was who would become the new emperor.
This would not be an easy thing to answer. In fact,
the collapse of another ans nine dynasty plunged the Roman empire into the most
turbulent period of its history. So far in 193,
85 men would vie for power and in one way or another,
each one of them would lay claim to the Roman throne eventually after betrayals
conspiracies, and just fascinations, only one would emerge triumphant,
ready to forge his own dynasty.
Following the chaos known as the year of the five emperors.
Um.
Some communists have perished.
He had made sworn enemies out of the Roman Senate.
Therefore they immediately went to work.
I'm doing many of the changes he had brought on and even had him declared a
public enemy of Rome. They realized that news of his demise would create chaos.
So they kept his death a secret until they already have someone lined up to
follow him as emperor that someone with pattern ax, according to the Astoria,
Augusta and Cassius DEO person,
X was born in Alba Pompeia in 126,
eight D it did not come from a noble family as his father.
Olivia successes was a freed man,
meaning a former slave who had gained his freedom, personal acts, received idea,
motorist education, and originally intended to become a teacher,
but found that military life was more to his liking with the help of a family,
friends who was a former console.
He obtained a position as a cohort prefect in Syria,
as the years went by pass the next steadily Rose through the ranks,
especially after distinguished himself in the Patheon war during the reigns of
Antonia's pass. And Mark's a rebellious person. X spent decades in the military,
moving from Syria to Britain, then maritia to Daisha.
He became a trusted aid of Claudia's bomb bareness.
One of the most important commanders under Marcus Aurelius and for his efforts,
it was granted several governorships and to console ship before being finally
assigned to the Senate. And when communists was dead,
two men who had been involved in his assassination electors and latest
concluded, the person acts had the rank,
the experience and the popularity to become the new emperor.
When he was told of this person acts first sends a companion to see the body of
the former emperor. Indeed,
the reign of kilometers that made a lot of men paranoid,
and they feared that something like this could be a test that might end in their
execution offer. He was convinced of the truth.
Pasternack's went to the Praetorian barracks to get them on his site.
Basically he told them that communists died of natural causes and promised them
a money gift called a donate of them.
So they would support is essential to the throne. Finally,
he went to the Senate where he stated his case, but also offered to step down.
If someone younger Angeles feeble than him was more suitable for the job,
I don't really,
it was this modesty and his practice accountancy that convinced the Senate,
that patent acts was the best candidate. So on January, the first 193 Ady,
he was crowned the new Roman emperor.
The people of Rome seemed pleased at this developments as they Johns or the name
pattern acts and slung, insults, communists,
and angry mobiles demanded the former emperor, his body.
So they could drag it through the streets and tear it to pieces.
But as it had already been in touch,
they have to set that smashing up the statues of communists by all accounts,
Pasinex trying to be a good ruler.
Cassius dos said that he showed humaneness and integrity and capital
consideration for the public welfare. He also wanted a more democratic reign,
so he refused fancy complicated titles.
And instead stalled himself as chief of the Senate,
a very old position from before the days of the empire unsurprisingly person.
Next continued reversing.
Many of the policies instituted by commerce and was more in line with Marcus
Aurelius bends. Of course, this has gotten killed.
It won't surprise you to learn.
The pattern acts did not have a long reign after all.
We're going to go through five of them in a single yet.
His biggest mistake was angering. The Praetorian God,
technically they were meant to be an elite units of Rome's greatest soldiers who
acted as bodyguards and intelligence officers for the emperor. In reality,
though, they will.
One of the Empire's most corrupt institutions as the defacto armed forces inside
the city of Rome,
they knew that their support was important for an emperor and regularly bargains
their position into obtaining more money, power, and privileges.
It was not uncommon for the guard to turn against an Ambra once they felt that
it was time for a change,
or if they believe that a newcomer would be better suited to their interests as
soon enough,
the Praetorian guard were about to commit to the most heinous acts of their 300
year existence,
because Coleman has didn't really counter about reading Ram effectively.
And because he already had plenty of other enemies to worry about,
he made sure to always be on the good side of the Praetorian guard,
like granting them.
A lot of concessions person acts on the other hand was a strict and disciplined
military man and intended to reform the God by curtailing the loss of its
privileges applause against him was almost inevitable. In fact,
he survived the first one,
uncovering a conspiracy to use up the throne and replace him with a console
named Foucault afterwards around 200 to 300 soldiers of the Praetorian God
simply storms the palace. They struck out an ax down,
cut off his head and placed it on a spear. It was last ending,
his reign after 87 days.
That's where it spread through.
Rome of what the Praetorian guard did to protect acts.
Most city officials rans hide in their homes. One of them, however,
they immediately saw the opportunity placed in front of him and realized that
the throne was up for grabs. That man was a pre-con soul named Didier Juliana's.
He made his way to the Praetorian barracks,
but wasn't allowed inside the cabins was shocked to discover that somebody else
had the same idea as the prefect of Rome,
Titus Flavius Silva Kianna's as not only the prefects, but also pattern axes.
SELPA Kianna's originally went to the camp to try and smooth over the situation
with the Praetorians. This was before person acts had been assassinated,
but once he learns of the emperor, his demise,
he thought he might as well make a play for the throne.
So he offered the same people who had just murdered his son in Laura money gift.
If they would support as essential as the new emperor, Juliana's heard this.
And even though we had not been allowed in sunny, the camp,
he shouted at the soldiers that he would make them a better off up.
Now the Praetorian God understood the situation in front of them.
So they proceeded to start a bidding war between the two officials.
But when Cassius DEO told the story,
since he was actually a Senator in Rome at the time,
then ensued a most disgraceful business and one unworthy of Rome for just as
if it had been in some market or auction room,
both a city and its entire empire auctioned off the settlers were the ones who
would slay in their emperor.
And there would be buyers where Suffolk Yannis and Juliana's who've.
I do outbid each other one from the inside, the other, from the outside,
they gradually raised their bids up to 20,000, says to seize per soldier,
some of the soldiers would carry words. Juliana's Slovakian this office so much.
How much more do you make it?
And to Suffolk Yonas and 10 Giuliani's promises so much,
how much do you raise him in the end? Did he,
as Juliana's offer 25,000 says to seize per soldier,
which roughly means around 65,000 to $75,000 in modern currency.
He also argued that if [inaudible] were to become emperor,
he might attempt to avenge person axes death.
This also was enough to sway the Praetorian guard who decided to make Diddy as
Juliana's the new emperor of Rome later, that same night,
really honest rode through the streets of Rome with the guard by his side,
weapons out and standards held high as they made their way to the forum.
And then to the Senate house,
this was an intimidation tactic and it sent a clear message.
The Praetorian guard supported.
Did he as Julianas and anyone who opposed him would have to deal with them going
back to dos accounts, who again was a Senator at the time,
he said there was a genuine fear among his peers Juliana's has called upon them
to come to the Senate house and confirm his emperor ship.
But they were worried that those who had been friends of pattern acts or enemies
of Juliana's would simply be put to death. Indeed, Cassius DEO was both yet.
Then granted a prayer to our ship by a pattern acts.
And I'd also accused Juliana's of several offenses,
but that was also concerned that those who skipped the meeting would simply be
hunted down in their homes. So with a lot of trepidation,
the senators made the waves of the meeting place,
genuinely not knowing if they would be leaving the Senate alive that night.
But again, let's hear from the firsthand accounts of the man who was that.
So when Boff and dinner were over, we pushed our way through the soldiers,
entered the Senate house and heard them deliver a speech that was quite worthy
of him. And the course of which he said, I see that you need to reload,
runs I myself and best fitters of any two rule.
You should mention all the advantages I can offer.
If you are not already familiar with them and had not already had experience of
me, consequently, I have not even asked to be attended here by many soldiers,
but have come to you alone in order that he may ratify what has been given to me
by them. I'm here alone is what he said, though.
You'd actually surrounded the entire Senate house outside with heavily armed
troops and a large number of soldiers in the chamber itself. Moreover,
he reminded us if our knowledge of the kind of man he was in consequence of
which we both feared and hated him with no other choice.
The Senate confirms did. He, as Juliana's says, the emperor of Romans,
he went to the palace that night,
where he had a feast and celebrated with games and music.
While the copes of his predecessor still lay on the palace floor.
The next day arrived, broke out as the people of our own firmly rejected,
really honest as a legitimate emperor. However,
they stood no chance against the Praetorian garden.
And he was slain in the clashes that followed.
Right.
By buying the loyalty of the Praetorian guards Juliana's might have had a firm
grip on Rome,
but the Roman empire was much bigger than just one city and to the God who
might've been fed by sentences and common citizens.
But what about an actual army?
What about Rome's greatest generals who commanded the loyalty of their soldiers,
volleyball and whomever was sitting in the Roman palace.
Would they simply roll over and accept Juliana's as their new leader,
especially after a blatant and shameful Ascension that was decried by both
politicians and PBNs alike? Well, no, of course not.
But this was called the a of the five emperors after role. We've had two so far.
So three more were coming well,
unlike person acts and Juliana at SU followed each other in sequence,
the other three made a play for the throne.
At the same time they were presenting this Septimius Severus and Claudius are
Binus. They shared similar circumstances. All three were successful,
respected Roman generals who were popular with the men under their command.
At the time, all of them were serving as governors,
several as in Pannonia Alanis in Britain and Pacino's in Syria,
once word reached them of what did he,
as Juliana's had done them and all recognized them as the new emperor and agreed
to March on Rome on their behalf,
there are three groups that it would be Roman leader has to contend with the
army, the centers and the common people with two hours of three,
there essentially is pretty much a done deal.
Purely has showed us that you can have even just one of them,
then get the second one by force and not care about the third.
But these three generals all have their own armies.
And it's a pretty safe bet that the sentence and the people of Rome would have
preferred any of them over duteous Juliana's. So,
which one would win in the end?
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] was born circa 135,
a D in a small town called acronym and provincial Italy.
He came from more modest means compared to his rivals and as part of an
equestrian family, we don't know much about his early career,
but his military record. I want him to rise above his station,
eventually becoming the first member of his family to become a Senator under two
kilometers off to several governorships and console ships throughout the empire.
But sending us ended up in Syria in 191. And by all accounts,
he was well liked by the people in Syria and by the senators back in Rome,
in terms of military supports pretty much the entire middle Eastern section of
the empire was behind him, Syria, Egypt, Jerusalem Arabia, and Kapha dosha.
If the Romans had it their way,
it would seem that they would have probably wants a sentience to be.
Then you emperor, according to DEO,
it was his name that the citizens shouted and praised whenever Juliana's was out
in public, unfortunately for them,
but [inaudible] was the furthest one of all stationed at the Eastern edge of the
Roman empire. The closest one was Septimius Severus. He was in Pannonia.
This was a Roman province right next to Italy,
born in Africa and 145 AED in the ancient port city of leptos Magna Severus was
the son of a Roman mother and to Carthaginian father.
He first traveled to right when he was 18 and began working his way up through
the ranks of the Roman public office,
which was also referred to as the curses sauna room,
this culminated in 191 80 with the governorship of Pannonia also under
[inaudible] DEO described Severus as the shrewdest of the four men fighting for
the throne.
As soon as the art of the death of Patton ACCE made preparations to go to Rome
and become the new emperor.
He got the supportive most of the soldiers in central and Eastern Europe,
while those in Britain goal and the Iberian peninsula well behind Claudius
Albeniz speaking of whom I'll ask contender was born Seneca 147 and possibly
in the African city of [inaudible] located in modern day. Tunisia,
we say possibly because the main source of as his early life,
his history or gusta, which is notoriously unreliable,
like the other two Alvin was made a governor by calmness Septimius Severus
because he was stationed close to Italy.
He was the first to make his way towards Rome.
A calculating man Severus realized that even if he did not take the throne,
he would immediately have two powerful rivals to contend with.
Neither of the other two were likely to give up their claim just because Diddy
Juliana's was no longer emperor.
Therefore he sought out a packed with ominous and he sent a letter where Severus
agreed to recognize him as Caesar. If he were to remain in Britain.
We're not sure exactly if this meant that the two would rule together or if
Severus offered to appoints. The other governor is his ad,
but this was good enough for Albeniz who stayed put the at least for now,
as far as Juliana's was concerned,
he offered little resistance to Septimius Severus first tried to send prefects
into messages to him, either to delay as Von. So to persuade his men,
to abandon him, however,
the opposite happens and more of them ended up siding with Severus.
The general then captured Ravenna runs its fleas without a fight it's most of
the populace he encountered preferred him over Juliana's. According to DEO,
there was one battle between the Praetorians and several of his forces,
but the Praetorians were absolutely crushed and did nothing worthy of their
name. And of that promise.
The historian thinks that this was because the Praetorians had become too
complacent or had learned live delicately as he put it.
They were fine when they threatened old senators or winds up against citizens,
armed with rocks, but got demolished by an actual battle-hardened army.
Other sources say the battle was not even necessary as the Victorians abandoned
Juliana's or masses Severus advanced in a desperate attempt.
Juliana's went to the Senate and asked them to talk to sever so that the two of
them could rule together. Of course, it was far too late for such offers.
One sever sent word to ruin that he would spare the Praetorians.
As long as they surrendered the ones who assassinated Patten acts,
his fate was sealed. The gods arrested Juliana's in terms of over to the Senate,
he was then sentenced to death. Septimius Severus was proclaims.
The new emperor and person acts was dafydd.
Did he S Giuliana was executed on the 1st of June,
193 Ady after just 66 days. His emperor is barely remember today,
but what he did was almost impressive in a way is he managed to become as hated
by the Romans, if not more so, as notorious emperors, like Caligula or Nero.
And he did it in just two months.
September.
Sever, as well as the new ruler of the Roman empire,
but he still had a few threats to deal with. But starters,
the Praetorians clearly they could not be trusted.
He might've promised to spend their lives,
but that did not mean he could have punish them.
He summons them moulins after chastising them for their actions against Pasinex.
He confiscated their arms and horses and banished them all from Rome now onto
the most serious threat percentile.
So clearly had no intention of giving up his claims at the throne. Fortunately,
for Severus. He also had the weaker army and according to dos, the week of mind,
he was getting too cocky and more puffed up than ever as the historian puts his
and hearing all this stuff about the people challenging his name in the streets
of Raymond's his own soldiers referring to him as the new Alexander went to his
hand, he was a session of victory,
but it was about to have a very rude awakening,
but sending us set up headquarters in Byzantines,
the city deeply loyal to him from them.
He marched his army and met severs in battle for the first time that year at the
city of [inaudible] not only was he defeated,
but one of his most trusted generals, Emily Ana's was slain.
Not surprisingly Severus captured the pressure on after his victory and laid
siege on Byzantium, forcing him to retreat further East. It's a nice app.
Another battle took place there in December,
and it resulted in another triumph Septimius Severus.
But then he has his Imperial dreams starting to shatter.
Not only did he suffer multiple defeats,
but he was beginning to lose supporters.
Some provinces like Egypt and Arabia switched their allegiances to Severus.
One final push was all it would take to finally break him.
It didn't happen until 193,
but it did occur the following year at is this during one last major battle
between the two sides, but sending us not only lost again,
but was captured by the enemy during his retreat, he was headed.
And then several centers had on a pole to buy Santiam,
which was still under siege in an effort to get them to finally abandon their
loyalty to him. It actually took two more years before by Santiam fell.
But once that happened, Severus his position was secured.
That was just one problem left Claudius business.
The last remaining pretended to the throne,
he was proclaimed emperor at the same time as Severus,
but the two of them forged a tenuous Alliance with Albertus accepting the title
of Caesar and ruling over most Western parts of the Ambar while its Severus was
dealing with [inaudible],
but business was fully expecting to one day become and burrow should sever die
before him.
But the latter had no intention of allowing this to happen and probably never
did several sent two sons and he wanted to follow him as emperor,
not Albertus first,
Severus tried using trickery and sent a senescence to Albeniz under the guise of
messengers. They failed. However, and now there was no choice,
but open combat between them.
I want to S began mobilizing his troops in Britain and proclaimed himself,
sole emperor. Well Severus did the same,
except that he named his eldest son as his co emperor and later 196 Ady
Albeniz and his forces crossed into Gaul. [inaudible] February the 19th,
197, a D at the battle of Dunham modern day, Neil France.
This would have been a massive conflict for the time is dimensions that each
side had 150,000 soldiers.
The tide turned several times as neither one dominated the field of battle,
but ultimately Septimius Severus was triumphant. Once more,
Alvin has retreated to look Dunham, but once the war was lost,
he killed himself. Severus took his hands and sent it to Rome,
making it clear that he finally.
Supreme.
The content is out of the way.
There was nobody left to challenge the authority of Septimius Severus it
might've technically lasted over four years,
but the year of five emperors was finally over and the, and dynasty could begin.
First came a show of dominance is Severus look to punish all of those who showed
support to his enemies, particularly in the Eastern parts of the empire,
which had aligned themselves with Fresenius. There were executions,
there were accels and there was a lot of confiscation of property offer all
Severus had grand ambitions of conquest, and those don't come cheap.
His first military campaign took place in 197, 80 against puffier,
like many Roman emperors before him.
He was moderately successful and it's captured some territory. But in the end,
despite two long seizures, he failed to conquer the fortified city of hotrod,
just like Trajan had failed almost a century prior.
His other main military campaign was in Britain in 280 D where he intended to
conquer Caledonia, which roughly corresponds to Scotland.
Nowadays his initial foray was successful,
even though it came with heavy casualties.
As the Caledonian is refused to engage in open combat and kept utilizing
guerrilla warfare by 210 80, the enemy had been defeated and left no choice,
but to Sue for peace,
but the terms were so one-sided that they rebel just a few months later,
it's Everest prepared for a second concussion.
This one with the intent of wiping out the Caledonian is completely,
his orders were less. No one escaped sheer destruction, no one, our hands,
not even the babe in the womb of the mother, if it'd be male,
let it nevertheless, not escape sheer destruction.
He did not live to see his orders. Camry out though.
Severus was already sick and stricken with gout and arthritis.
He fell ill during the campaign and feeling it was the end.
He retreated Borica more York as we call it today and died on the 4th of
February 211,
eight deep before his demise Severus had made his youngest son get her co member
as well with hopes that he would reign alongside his older brother.
This would not come to pass. However,
as his eldest would go on to become one of the cruelest tyrants,
do you ever sit on the Roman throne,
but we will explore that story another day and we take a look at the rain of
Cara, Carla. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to subscribe.
Yes. Thank you for watching.
[inaudible].